en este vídeo vamos a hablar de otra
manera de visualizar los datos y su
nombre es el histograma histograma y
bueno a pesar de tener este nombre tan
caprichoso no es un concepto tan
caprichoso y quisiera comentar que es
una forma muy utilizada para visualizar
datos en estadística ahora te mostraré
cómo hacemos una historia a partir de
datos y pienso que te vas a dar cuenta
de la idea con mucha facilidad tengo
aquí un conjunto de datos y voy a
construir un programa a partir de ellos
lo que tengo que observar es la
frecuencia con la que aparecen cada uno
así que voy a escribirlos aquí abajo y
voy a categorizar los aquí tengo un 1 si
tengo un 1 lo pongo aquí después tengo
un 4 y voy a dejar espacio para poner a
los demás así que este el 4 después
tengo un 2
después tengo otro uno y lo voy a apilar
al primero tengo un cero y este lo voy a
poner a la izquierda del 1 los quiero
poner todos en orden luego tengo un 2 y
lo voy a pilar donde está el primer 2
tengo otro 1 y también lo voy a apilar
con los unos luego tengo otro 0
otro uno
luego tengo otros dos lo pongo aquí y
luego otro uno luego vienen dos ceros y
luego vienen 22 así que los pongo aquí
un 3
luego tengo dos unos más
otro 3
y luego tengo un 6 no hay 5 así que aquí
pongo el 6 lo que hice fue reescribir
los en categorías y ahora lo que voy a
hacer es calcular cuántos tengo de cada
uno
voy a acomodar la pantalla y calcular la
frecuencia de cada uno de estos números
la frecuencia así que tengo 1 2 3 4
ceros y tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 unos después
tengo 1 2 3 4 5 2 1 2 3 1 4 y tengo 16
así que lo voy a escribir así el número
si el número y su frecuencia
la frecuencia
así que en números tengo 0 1 2 3 4
también está el 5 con frecuencia 0 y el
6 así que el 0 apareció cuatro veces el
1 apareció 7 veces el 2 5 veces el 2
apareció 5 veces el 3 2 veces el 4 una
vez el 5 no apareció ninguna vez y el 6
una vez todo lo que hice fue contar este
conjunto de datos
cuántas veces aparece el 0 1 2 3 4
cuantas veces aparece el 1 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
y eso es lo que entendemos por
frecuencia y un historia ma en realidad
sólo es una gráfica de estas frecuencias
es una especie de gráfica de barras que
se parece mucho a lo que hice al inicio
así que voy a dibujar mi eje aquí y en
este caso los intervalos serán exactos
con los números en nuestro ejemplo
ocurre que tenemos repeticiones de
números enteros si los datos no fueran
números que se repiten exactamente
tendríamos que hacer intervalos o rangos
para estos datos ponemos el 0 1
2 3 4 5 y 6 y en la vertical pondremos
las frecuencias si lo construimos
poniendo las frecuencias en la vertical
así 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 así que el
cero aparece cuatro veces si el cero
está cuatro veces y es la información
que tengo aquí
después el 1 aparece 7 veces sí claro el
17 veces y voy a dibujar una barra que
se vea más o menos mejor más derecha sí
que se vea hasta el 7
ahora vamos con el 2 el 2 aparece 5
veces y voy a usar otro color
entonces pongo una barra que llegue
justo hasta el 5 ahí está el 3 aparece
dos veces también con su color ponemos
hasta la altura del 2 una barra para el
3 y ahora vamos el 4 aparece una vez
una vez el 4 ahí estamos
el 4 el 5 no aparece ninguna vez así que
nada más lo indicamos el 6 aparece una
vez y aquí dibujamos hasta la altura del
1 su barra que se observe que el 6
aparece una vez y lo que he dibujado
aquí es un historia ma sí una historia
ma estas palabras tan caprichosa estarán
de acuerdo conmigo que el concepto es
una idea muy simple solo son las
frecuencias de estos números que tenemos
aquí y eso es todo lo que hay en un
programa